i think we did a very good job of
getting everybody that we could get uh
that we could get out and we think the
citizens that were not brought out
number in the low very low hundreds low
hundreds no we don't exactly know but
it's in the low hundreds at least it's
not the high hundreds or the thousands
or something it's the low hundreds
pathetic
let's talk for a second about the actual
acute issue
america is now admitting that we left
people behind
that's an unbelievable statement
now jimmy carter became not president
because there were 50 americans who are
taken hostage in iran we have left at
the very least 250 americans under the
tender care of the taliban plus
thousands of green card holders plus
tens of thousands of people who worked
with us
now this administration's been lying
about this all along remember it was
just a couple of weeks ago that joe
biden said if there are american
citizens left behind we'll get them out
remember he said this to george
stephanopoulos this is like
a week and a half ago
are you committed to making sure that
the troops stay until every american who
wants to be out is out
yes how about our afghan allies does the
commitment hold for them as well
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31 but if we don't
the troops if we don't we'll determine
at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to get them all out liar liar liar
godly liar what a liar he is what a liar
remember jen's hockey got very upset
with peter ducey for saying they're
americans stranded in kabul again this
is a week and a half ago
i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home we are
going to bring them home and i think
that's important for the american public
to hear and understand it's important
for the american public to be lied to by
jen saki every single day repeatedly
and then for all of her cheerleaders in
the press to start clapping like seals
so um here was the head of centcom
general mackenzie yesterday saying yeah
we didn't get everybody out
there's a lot of heartbreak associated
with this departure we did not get
everybody out that we wanted to get out
but i think if we stayed another 10 days
louie we wouldn't have gotten everybody
out that we wanted to get out and there
still would have been people who would
have been disappointed with that it's a
it's a tough situation but i want to
emphasize again that simply because we
have left that doesn't mean the
opportunities for both americans that
are in afghanistan that want to leave
and uh and afghans who want to leave
they will not be denied that opportunity
i think our department of state is going
to work that very hard in the days and
weeks oh man the department of state is
going to work it's super hard we'll get
to the department of state in a second
they're going to tickle the hell out of
those taliban members they're going to
hit them with pillows made of foam
they're going to send them some strongly
worded statements to those illiterate
cavemen let me just tell you that
what a humiliation i mean really like if
you're general mckenzie at some point
don't you just have to say i'm not going
out there and i'm going to repeat this
garbage
aren't you going to say like get
somebody else to be your spokesperson on
this because this is pathetic
is that what yeah man i mean we're we're
taking out all of the we're taking out
the most powerfully armed military in
the history of the world but let me tell
you ned price and that team over at
state tony blinken he's gonna be
on his phone with those people at the
other end of the phone they're going to
be picking up an actual rock connected
to a wire like fred flintstone and
they're going to be talking to him and
let me tell you we're going to exert
such unbelievable leverage
we are going to absolutely threaten not
to open a planned parenthood in kabul
unless they give us back our people
i mean we are going to send them so much
literature about their lack of
opportunity
for lgbtq people in afghanistan
we are going to chide them so hard
we are not going to send them a pride
progress flag unless they let our people
out
our state department will not stand for
any of this sort of stuff
pathetic
here's general mackenzie explaining oh
you know they're just low hundreds low
hundreds no we don't exactly no but it's
in the low hundreds at least it's not
the high hundreds or the thousands or
something it's the low hundreds
oh the low hundreds you mean like at
least five times as many people as the
iranians had during the uh hostage
crisis of 79 interesting
the military phase of this operation has
ended the diplomatic sequel to that will
now begin and i believe our department
of state is going to work very hard to
allow any american citizens that are
left and we think the citizens that were
not brought out number in the low very
low hundreds uh i believe that we're
going to work we're going to be able to
get those people out i think we're also
going to negotiate very hard and very
aggressively to get our other afghan
partners out
we're gonna go
it's negotiate hard
with john mcclane
so much negotiation
underneath this pillow i have a gun and
underneath this gun i have another
pillow
that that last pillow is the one i'm
going to be using in this negotiation
you removed every capacity we had you
removed all the leverage we had you're
now begging the taliban and by the way
you're going to bribe them the only
question is whether you're going to do
it illegally the bind administration is
now claiming as we will see that they
are going to funnel the money through
the u.n which presumably will make it
legal
which by the way we've done before i
mean we fund the unrwa which funds
terror groups all over the uh the
palestinian authority and hamastan so
why not we can do it here too
general mckenzie said you know we
couldn't get everybody out but we did do
a good job given the challenges yes i
mean who created those challenges
what are those challenges i didn't i
wasn't aware there were any challenges i
was told this was smooth it was all part
of the plan
so funny how you mentioned there are
challenges
would you like to discuss what those
challenges were and how they got there
general mackenzie or would you prefer to
continue kissing the feet of the people
who continue to maintain your position
at the head of centcom
you would like to bring out everybody
that wanted to come out we're not able
to do that situation wouldn't allow it i
think we did a very good job of getting
everybody that we could get uh that we
could get out given the unique change
the challenges of the tactical situation
on the ground the fact that really not
if not all americans wanted to leave
they're americans that for a variety of
reasons want to stay for a while i think
we'll go back and they'll have the
opportunity to uh they'll have the
opportunity to revisit that and come out
if they want
um yeah right also by the way remember
how we left early we left early not only
did we leave early none of the last jets
had americans on them so for all this
talk about how we were working until the
last minute to get people out we
absolutely were not here's mckenzie
saying yep no we sent some empty jets
back
no american citizens came out on the
last what we call the joint tactical
exfiltration the last five jets to leave
we we maintained the ability to bring
them in up until immediately before
departure but we were not able to bring
any americans out that activity ended
probably about 12 hours before our exit
although we continued the outreach and
would have been prepared to to bring
them on until the very last minute but
none of them made it to the airport and
were able to be and were able to be
accommodated
so you know no biggie we left early and
we have a bunch of people behind and the
last few flights were empty but we did a
great job mackenzie also is playing
defense for the taliban which of course
they have to do if you surrender to a
group of people who obviously are
outclassed by you militarily you have to
have an excuse the excuse from this
administration is that the taliban are
now our friends they're our best friends
now here's general mackenzie
just unreal talking about how wonderful
the taliban have been
i will tell you the taliban have been
very pregnant very pragmatic and very
business-like as we have approached this
uh withdrawal we did not turn it over to
the taliban uh general donahue one of
the last things he did before leaving
was talk to the taliban commander that
he had been coordinating with as soon as
with about the time we were going to
leave just to let them know that we were
leaving but there was no discussion of
turning anything over uh of that at all
they they were pragmatic they were
business-like you know really i was kind
of surprised at their pragmatism in
their business-like manner
as they allowed a suicide bomber to kill
a bunch of americans uh and as they
threatened to kill all of our allies and
were dragging people out into the
streets house by house and beating women
it was really pragmatic though i mean
super duper pragmatic
okay in a second we're going to get to
the state department which again remains
when you talk about the quote unquote
deep state you know career bureaucrats
who continue to design policy despite
being lifelong incompetence the state
department is the repository of all
these near due wells it's just a
repository of useless human beings how's
this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang